Fleur Magick Dennis
It’s a really Aussie thing, that parents have done all the time
is put the sprinkler on for the kids in the heat in summer.
Fleur Magick Dennis
That’s what Australian poor families have always done.
Like I grew up playing in the sprinkler in summer to beat the heat.
Fleur Magick Dennis
We can’t do that. None of the towns can do that because everyone’s on water restrictions and we’re not supposed to have the sprinklers running.
The whole time that we’ve been fighting for water here in our village,
Fleur Magick Dennis
it’s only been for basic use.
We’re only allowed to use our allocated water for drinking,
Fleur Magick Dennis
flushing the toilet, washing, cooking.
Just general household use.
Fleur Magick Dennis
And we had to fight really, really, really hard
to even get that basic water allowance.
Fleur Magick Dennis
That really concerned me why that would be the case,
in a first world country.
Fleur Magick Dennis
My little son who’s seven, he said to me the other day,
“Mum, when I grow up I’d love to buy some land and grow bush tucker
Fleur Magick Dennis
… if we survive.”
I said, “What do you mean, ‘if we survive’?”.
Fleur Magick Dennis
He said, “Well, if we survive climate change.”
And I was in a lot of shock over his comment.
Fleur Magick Dennis
Even though he’s only seven
he’s aware that it’s a survival issue at the moment,
Fleur Magick Dennis
that climate change is so worrying to him as a seven-year-old.
That’s he’s just so worried about his future.